hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction thriller film
called freaks
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
seven-year-old chloe has never been out
of an abandoned house she lives with her
father henry her mother died years ago
the movie starts as we see chloe eyeing
an ice cream van outside her house
through a hole
there are some strange things outside
chloe's house we see that the birds
outside are not moving and appear to be
glitching the electricity in the house
is always out and there seems to be no
life outside the house
henry always gets furious when she peaks
outside she is forbidden to leave the
house in fear of the bad man who killed
her mother henry is unsure of his safety
so he has prepared a plan in case
something bad happens to him he has made
a deal with their neighbor the reed's
family in case of his absence the reeds
will be paid a steady amount of cash as
long as they take care of his daughter
the family consists of a daughter named
harper a mother named nancy and a father
named steve
one day as the two play poker henry's
eyes start to bleed that night while
sleeping chloe heard a strange noise
from her closet
she opens it to check when suddenly a
woman inside the closet screams chloe
two yells in fear she runs back to her
bed and starts to scribble on the wall
repeating the words go away ghost
finally the screaming stops and the
ghost is gone the following morning
chloe wakes up to the sound of an ice
cream truck and peeks through a window
her neighbor's daughter harper is buying
ice cream she whispers to harper to
bring it to her knowing that she won't
hear it however soon after someone
knocks on the doors chloe rushes
downstairs and opens the door
surprisingly it is harper offering her
the ice cream just as she is about to
grab it henry from behind her stops her
surprisingly again harper calls chloe by
her name henry is confused as he has
never introduced chloe to anyone so he
quickly brings her inside henry is
furious and asks her if she had met
harper before but chloe insists that she
has never been out of the house but he
doesn't believe her and puts her into
the closet as a punishment
the following morning henry comes into
the closet and apologizes to her but she
is still mad at him and insists that she
wants to go out henry promises to bring
her ice cream if she never opens the
door again
he then leaves for the grocery store but
comes back injured with a gun in his
hand as he mends his injuries chloe
looks for ice cream in the basket he has
brought and finds no ice cream she
starts to yell at her father but he
passes out because of the injury
just then chloe hears the ice cream
truck ringing she gets a hundred dollar
bill from the locker and goes outside
the old man in the truck bribes her with
an ice cream cone and persuades her to
get inside the truck she is doubtful but
gets in once he says he will take her to
the park
they drive away and chloe sees the
outside world for the first time
she sees a billboard of a person
bleeding from his eyes below the picture
it says to call 911 if you see someone
like that chloe mentions that the man
bleeds like her dad the old man then
asks her if she has ever bled like that
but chloe denies it when they reach the
park the man sits chloe on a swing and
asks her if there is something she can
do that other people cannot but chloe
doesn't answer too busy playing
suddenly he starts to swing her
aggressively chloe is scared and asks
him to stop but the man tries to make
her angry to surface her powers
eventually a policeman approaches them
and asks him to step away from the girl
the old man claims that he is chloe's
grandfather but chloe denies it the
officer then asks alan to show his eyes
allen turns to chloe and tells him that
the officer is one of the bad guys who
killed her mother chloe becomes upset
and starts screaming at the man to go
away
surprisingly it works he goes away
without another word it turns out that
chloe has telepathic abilities the
ability to enter and manipulate other
people's minds the old man begins to
realize that chloe is a special child
and brings her back home
on their way he tells chloe about her
mother mary and gives her a picture of
her he reveals that he is actually
chloe's grandfather alan before parting
ways he gives her a powder and tells her
to drug her dad when she hears the ice
cream truck ring this will make henry
fall asleep and chloe can go to the park
she takes the powder and goes inside a
few hours later henry wakes up and sees
chloe in her room drawing
she accuses him of lying about the bad
people outside the house and the two get
into a fight that night she looks at
mary's picture and imagines her
suddenly the closet starts making noise
again chloe goes in and sees the ghost
she had seen a few days ago but now she
recognizes her as her mother mary
she introduces herself but mary pushes
her away saying that chloe isn't real
and just a hallucination so chloe runs
out of the closet turns out that chloe
also has a long-distance telepathic
ability and could make other people at a
distance see and talk to her
in the morning the father is sleeping
while watching the news chloe silently
listens to the news
from the news chloe finds out that they
are strange people often called the
freaks freaks have super abilities
causing their eyes to bleed out when
they use them ten years ago a freak
messed up the city of dallas and killed
thousands of people
since then a government has set up a
defense force against strange people
called the adf the adf arranges for all
freaks to be held in an underground
facility on mount matic and freaks
roaming the city are considered illegal
and could be killed immediately an adf
agent named agent ray reveals her plan
to train the freaks on mount matic to be
used as weapons and battles
after hearing the news chloe is
devastated she hopes that one day she
will be adopted by the reeds family so
that she can become a normal family
member and have a mother figure who
loves her
later chloe is playing with paper toys
wishing that she lived with harper just
then harper and her friends arrive in
the room
harper screams at chloe asking her why
she is in her room the two seem to be in
their respective room but somehow have
met each other because of chloe's power
harper's friends make fun of chloe for
not having a mother chloe cries and
screams
when she opens her eyes harper and her
friends are gone and mary appears in the
closet at first her mother doesn't
believe it is her daughter and thinks it
is just a hallucination but she begins
to realize that chloe has telepathic
powers and that it is really her chloe
starts talking to her mother it turns
out that chloe's mother mary is also a
freak and she is still alive and being
held in mount matic but not long after
her mother suddenly disappears again the
next morning chloe tells henry about her
mother but he doesn't believe her
seeing no other way to escape she tries
to drug her father
henry realizes what she's doing and
chases her to the door
she commands him to sleep and he slips
down to the floor as chloe's eye bleeds
for the first time
she meets ellen in his truck and he
tells her about his plan
allen explains that chloe's mother is
still alive but is being held captive on
mount matic he plans to go to mount
matic by meeting an adf agent ray
allen takes chloe to see agent rey he
then makes up a story about him being a
priest and chloe being his adopted
daughter he lies that he has just found
out that chloe is a freak he asks agent
ray to protect chloe and take her to
mount matic and allen also wants to go
there to accompany chloe then agent ray
checks for traces of blood under chloe's
eyes to make sure she's a freak
ray also checks allen's eyes but finds
no traces under his being called a freak
chloe gets offended and yells that she
is not a freak reed calls for backup
thinking that chloe is dangerous
luckily alan and chloe managed to escape
by suddenly disappearing it turns out
that alan is also a freak who has the
ability to become invisible he has been
using hydrogen peroxide to remove the
traces of blood under his eyes the two
flee from there chloe asks him to take
her back home but he wants to take chloe
to his apartment to teach her how to use
her power so they can help chloe's
mother she uses her power to make him
drive home suddenly henry appears on the
road and he takes allen in his truck and
they just disappear
he takes allen home and ties him to a
chair
moments later henry returns to chloe he
begins to explain everything to chloe it
turns out that all this time henry is
also a freak he has the ability to
create a time bubble that slows time in
the outside world while the person
inside the bubble performs normally all
this time he had created a time bubble
around their house which worked as long
as he wasn't asleep to the rest of the
world it had only been a few months
since chloe's mother was arrested but to
the two of them they had been hiding in
the house for seven years
deciding it's time to finally let chloe
go henry takes her to the reeds to
fulfill their deal steven agrees and
introduces them to nancy and harper
nancy soon realizes that chloe is a
freak and backs out of the deal saying
that she didn't know they were supposed
to be taking in a freak
finally they leave while begging the
reads to not report them to the police
back in the house henry is shocked to
see chloe's eyes bleeding and realizes
that she already has super abilities
afraid to trust her henry puts her in
the closet there she meets her mother
mary who is being held at mount matic
but suddenly the prison guard drags mary
outside when chloe comes out of the
closet she tells henry about her mother
at first henry does not believe her but
finally allen explains everything it
turns out that when he and mary attacked
mount matic they lost and allen managed
to escape but mary was captured he
thought mary was killed but it turns out
that mary was only detained
suddenly chloe sees her neighbor nancy
reporting them to the police chloe uses
her telepathic powers to get a vision of
what nancy is talking about
nancy calls chloe a freak agitated chloe
uses her power to influence the
policeman he stabs nancy's eye seeing
her eyes bleeding the adf agents assume
nancy is a freak and shoot her right
away the reed's family is eventually
arrested by the adf assuming they are
all freaks henry is mad at chloe for
killing someone but allen defends her
and they fight chloe immediately goes to
her room where she has a vision of mary
being captured henry and alan then come
and henry is shocked to see his wife
apparently mary will be put to death
soon henry tries to shoot the doctor but
of course he can because it is just an
illusion henry and alan bid farewell to
mary but suddenly khloe uses her
telepathic powers to control the
doctor's mind and uses the device to
kill himself
chloe enters the mind of the other
officer to free her mother just then the
doorbell rings it is agent rey she has
come to investigate them henry freezes
the time and dresses up as a realtor
trying to sell the house allen gives him
hydrogen peroxide to remove the blood
stains from his face he lets rey in and
checks henry for the blood stains when
she doesn't find any they talk for a
while it turns out that she already
knows who he is
meanwhile chloe is freeing mary from the
establishment allen comes to help henry
but before he can do anything ray shoots
him wounding him badly allen goes
invisible before she can do the same to
him
she then goes upstairs to see chloe
trying to free marry
she shoots her but alan comes in between
and saves chloe's life at the cost of
his agitated chloe controls rey's mind
and makes her shoot herself
she then says her last goodbye to her
grandfather
outside the police have surrounded the
house after hearing gunshots while chloe
continues saving her mother
she controls the guards who are about to
capture mary and makes them kill each
other she then opens the exit door for
mary and lets her free mary comes
outside and flies away using her power
chloe falls unconscious because of the
overuse of her power meanwhile a missile
then locks itself into the house and the
wounded henry uses his powers one last
time to slow it down he carries chloe
outside as the missile hits the house
burning it behind him when chloe wakes
up henry says his last goodbye and tells
her that he loves her henry dies from
his gunshot wound chloe mourns her
father's death when she hears gunshots
adf agents are still looking for chloe
trying to capture her
suddenly the shooting stops as mary
arrive on time to save her chloe and
mary meet for the first time and she
promises to hide and protect her forever
however chloe tells her that they don't
need to hide anymore and they can live
wherever they want touched by her
daughter's confidence mary flies away
with her hands around chloe subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching